[Musica]
e se vi chiedessi quali sono le
soluzioni per contrastare il cambiamento
climatico
voi che cosa mi rispondereste
sì lo so
lo so cosa state pensando
macchine elettriche
pale eoliche pannelli fotovoltaici
navicelle aerospaziali per colonizzare
marte
soluzioni ingegneristiche che con
straordinari macchinari e calcoli
complessi si impongono di ridurre le
emissioni di co2 in atmosfera pur
continuando a vivere però come abbiamo
sempre fatto
ebbene di fronte a problemi che delle
volte ci sembrano insormontabili
basterebbe fermarsi un attimo e
osservare chi ha a che fare con questi
problemi da milioni di anni
la natura
ci siamo sempre focalizzati sulle
risoluzioni strettamente tecnologica del
problema
dimenticando tuttavia il contributo
fondamentale che gli ecosistemi naturali
possono offrire nel contrastare il
cambiamento climatico in quanto sono
incredibili serbatoi di carbonio e di
biodiversità
biodiversità questa parola che oggi è un
po sulla bocca di tutti ma ma cosa vuol
dire vuol dire diversità in specie
diversità in forme in colori in
dimensioni diversità in soluzioni
gli ecosistemi naturali infatti coloro
complesso intreccio tra tutte le
componenti abiotiche l'acqua l'aria il
suolo idioti che tutte le specie
vegetali animali che compongono il
nostro pianeta sono infatti in grado di
fornire qualcosa di indispensabile al
nostro sistema la resilienza che rende
il nostro sistema in grado di rispondere
a un qualsiasi evento perturbante
per secoli il genere umano 6 schiato
alla natura
osservando ed imparando
pensate alla nostra vita quotidiana
pensate al colore dei nostri tessuti ai
farmaci al cibo che portiamo sulla
nostra tavola al volo dei droni degli
elicotteri ai colori stessi
così la natura allo stesso modo può
aiutarci nel trovare le soluzioni per
contrastare il cambiamento climatico che
sta rischiando di portare al collasso la
nostra e moltissime altre specie
il carbonio che noi tutti tristemente
associamo al cambiamento climatico
in realtà la componente fondamentale di
tutta la materia organica è l'elemento
base che ha permesso la vita organismi
come noi e tutta la restante diversità
vivente
il nostro pianeta questo elemento lo
conosce molto bene da miliardi di anni
infatti lo scambio lo combina nei cicli
tra gli esseri viventi e non
parte di questo carbonio può venire
sequestrato e immagazzinato all'interno
dei cosiddetti serbatoi di carbonio
naturale che altro non sono però che
ecosistemi in tutta la loro semplice
complessità
certo non dobbiamo immaginarci questi
serbatoi di carbonio come dei
compartimenti ha preso stagna che come
per magia intrappolano le gride
carbonica in eccesso e risolvono il
nostro però il problema
ma quanto più elementi del sistema
naturale gli alberi le rocce il suolo i
gusci stessi degli animali sono tutti i
serbatoi di carbonio naturale
in questo piccolo esempio che vi porto
in questo paper sono stati calcolati i
mega grammi di co2 intrappolati in
diversi ecosistemi terrestri per esempio
in un normale prato possono venire
immagazzinati fino a 200 m g di carbonio
per ettaro mentre in una zona umida che
la nostra il nostro territorio conosce
bene per lo meno conosceva bene fino a
400 m g
la domanda che oggi vi faccio è questa
di fronte alle immagini come queste
notti ghiacciai che si sciolgono
gli orsi polari scheletrici
incendi devastanti che privano della
propria casa e cuccioli orango tango ed
isole di rifiuti galleggianti che
inondano i mari di tutto il mondo
quante volte ci siamo sentiti impotenti
frustrati
certo i governi di tutto il mondo devo
iniziare a prendere decisioni più
lungimiranti che mirano a tutelare gli
ecosistemi la loro biodiversità ma nel
nostro piccolo
siamo sempre abituati a pensare alla
natura come qualcosa di lontano da noi
che ci vogliano ore di macchina se non
addirittura di euro per raggiungerla o
che l'unico modo di apprezzarla sia
attraverso coloratissimi documentari di
discovery channel
ma noi siamo nella natura attraverso
piccole è veramente semplice obbedire
greening le nostre città e addirittura i
nostri semplice balconi di casa i
giardini possono diventare incredibili
serbatoi di biodiversità
certo qui non siamo al polo nord non
stiamo salvando direttamente l'orso
polare ma stiamo contribuendo a tutelare
un anello di quella lunga catena che
compone gli ecosistemi dove ad ogni
nostra azione corrisponde una risposta e
se ci impegniamo a tutelare la natura
dietro casa stiamo finalmente diventando
attori di quel cambiamento di cui noi
ora stiamo soltanto parlando
certo il cambiamento è difficile cosa
serve per cambiare
beh secondo me la sfida sarà soprattutto
culturale e dovremmo aiutare la natura
ad aiutarci accogliendo nuovamente la
vita selvatica all'interno delle nostre
vite ma come farlo sembrano parole
difficilissimo ma io per esempio nel mio
comune sono conosciuta come la pazza che
vuole la giungla nelle aiuole la savana
ma un'immagine che mi dipinge tra il
bucolico e il disprezzo
perché chiedo semplicemente di non
sfalciare l'erba costantemente in estate
seppure questa idea possa sembrare
culturalmente folle a livello
scientifico invece trova invece un forte
riscontro positivo evidenziando come
lasciare ricard e piccoli ecosistemi
anche in contesti urbani fortemente
antropizzati migliori non solo
l'ambiente ma anche l'umore delle
persone
qui vi propongo di immagine la prima che
vedete il classico prato cosiddetta
l'inglese regolarmente sfalciato il
secondo invece è un prato lasciata
libera evoluzione non sfacciato
costantemente in questa ricerca sono
stati calcolati la quantità di insetti
impollinatori che noi oggi conosciamo
benissimo che sono in tutte le
pubblicità in un frate nell'altro
ma deve sorprendere che il nella seconda
immagine quindi nel secondo ambiente ci
siano tre volte il numero di specie
rispetto al prato all'inglese quindi ora
vi chiedo dov'è il serbatoio di
biodiversità con quale delle due ipotesi
stiamo contrastando il cambiamento
climatico
ma può l'erba alta
lasciata nel mio giardino
tutelare l'orango tango in asia
si indirettamente si così per molti
purtroppo io continuerò ad essere la
pazza che vuole la giungla nelle aiuole
ma per altri straw un esempio di come
essere una goccia che conta in mezzo al
mare e farlo guardate bene è facile
delle volte molto più semplice economico
meno faticoso meno dispendioso e
soprattutto non si disturbano vicine le
calde mattinate estive
ma come salvare il mondo la biodiversità
contrastare il cambiamento climatico
comodamente dal nostro divano di casa
per esempio ricreiamo piccole zone umide
nei nostri giardini privati pubblici
aiutiamo la flora e la fauna autoctona
so che la bici ha visto a tutti un po
niente tifo troy e l'omessa lo stesso
perché serve anche lei
quando vi chiedono quando volete una
pianta volete piantare un albero
scegliete e senza autoctone e senza cioè
che sono che vivono nel questo
ecosistema da milioni di anni hanno un
ruolo all'interno dei sistemi vi
costeranno anche molto meno
le foglie il legno morto non sono dei
rifiuti sono una risorsa
incominciamo a capirlo ma poi tutto
sommato un po di disordine è una cosa
buona e stimolante e divertente è meno
faticoso
certo un po meno per maniaci dell'ordine
quello che oggi voglio dirvi è che
sicuramente la tecnologia ha fatto passi
da gigante ha migliorato le nostre vite
aiutandoci a superare i problemi che
difficilmente avremmo risolto senza ma
la natura è l'unica fonte di risorse di
cui disponiamo
perché noi non ci possiamo nutrire di
computer né di reti wireless
quindi in un'epoca di grandi cambiamenti
come quella che stiamo vivendo sarà
fondamentale indispensabile
associare all'avanzamento tecnologico il
ripristino degli ambienti naturali
permettendo alla componente selvatica
del nostro pianeta di ridarci la
speranza
è un po come quando perdi qualcosa e sei
costretto a ritornare sui suoi passi per
ritrovarla
allo stesso modo la nostra specie di
aver il coraggio di fermarsi voltarsi e
guardare al futuro
riscoprendo nella tecnologia più vecchia
avanzata di sempre le soluzioni
la natura e non c'è niente di più
rassicurante eri sapere che tutti nel
nostro piccolo possiamo fare davvero
qualcosa e chiederlo poi nel nostro
grande ghiaccio
[Applauso]
[Musica]